[Music]
Chrissy Teigen and John Legend's
daughter is the cutest it's hard to
believe how fast Luna is growing up et
is taking a look back at her most
adorable moment so far look a cute thing
from getting a first glimpse at the
newborn - making her big snapchat debut
at just a few days old Luna
continues to melt our hearts she made
her mom's dreams come true by cooking
with Chrissy and here she is playing the
piano with her musician dad to practice
for lala land
then little Lou appeared in her first
music video for John song love me now
she was so good it was so easy we just
did like literally two takes with her
and because we had to like catch her and
while she was in a good mood and she
woke up from her nap and and had some
food so she was like just happy enough
we've seen several first from the tiny
tot her first Dodgers game
she doesn't set any words yet Lunas
first word what is that cat cat she's
crawling and like kind of propping
herself up like with the coffee table
she can stand herself up but she's not
walking it but it's a pretty fun time
then there's her first time successfully
blowing a kiss on Valentine's Day after
Chrissy tried to teach her for three
months and it's hard not to laugh when
little Luna gets the giggles don't do it
but the cutest moments might just be
from the holidays Luna didn't look happy
to meet Santa Claus but pulled it
together for a precious pick with the
Easter Bunny still nothing beats all her
adorable costumes for Halloween our
favorite Luna as Little Red Riding Hood
we're really enjoying this whole this
whole period of our lives and of her
life
[Music]